bonjour je m'appelle robin et si on ta
gloire je fais la régie alors là régis
et plusieurs choses mais le plus
important c'est la bouffe et oui parce
que la bouffe sur un tournage c'est le
nerf de la guerre ce que si par exemple
une actrice commence à avoir faim son
rang ce vacarme rouillé et la l'ingé son
avec son micro perche il va l'entendre
plaisir mais aussi j'ai faim hélas comme
ça comme une traînée de poudre ça va se
répandre et bientôt toute l'équipe a
faim est une équipe qui a faim ça peut
pas travailler efficacement
et là c'est là que j'interviens donne à
manger mais comme vous allez le voir
pour l'instant y'a rien à bouffer et
c'est là que vous intervenez
avec votre soutien on va pouvoir acheter
à manger pour que je puisse m'en allais
type qui va pouvoir en retour vous
fournir une bonne saison 2 de talloires
alors merci pour votre soutien
on compte sur vous